it's time for another update video and
this one is for october two thousand
sixteen so i'm going to talk about all
the great stuff we've got coming up in
october and what went on it in September
just in case you missed it I like to
begin every one of these videos by
talking about three big things I'm going
to give you a sort of bullet point form
for these and you're gonna have to stay
tuned to the October section to hear
more about them big thing number one
stoic week 2016 I'm participating as
editor of Stoicism today and as a
featured speaker at stoic on I'm also
doing some events here in the Milwaukee
area and some online so I'll talk about
that more in a moment second big thing
we are now using the teachable a web
platform for offering online courses
that learners can use to proceed at
their own pace the very first class that
we're going to be bringing out during
stoic week at the very end of stoic week
is going to be a free course on
Epictetus a--'s and karidian I'm going
to be releasing the 21 videos that I
shot earlier this summer so more about
that in a little bit third big thing is
another teachable class which i'll be
releasing towards the end of the month
this one actually costs a bit to take
but nothing remotely like what it costs
the students for whom it was originally
developed at a particular college that I
used to teach for its the world views
and values class everything that the
students were getting all the content
the videos the handouts the the cool
discussion questions I'm going to be
offering that in an online format to
learners anybody who wants it and we're
deliberately keeping the cost of that
course as low as possible so that as
many people as would like to participate
in it can can do so so those are the
three big things and keep an eye out for
them again we'll talk about that a
little bit
more in the October section so let's
talk now about the month of September
just in case you missed any of those
events or if you're interested in what
it is that I do here at reason I oh I
gave three talks or rather had three
events one of them was online one of
them was at the Shorewood public library
and it was a version of my ethics of
anger talk this is a talk that I can
adapt to a lot of different
circumstances anything from a 30-minute
talk to a four hour half day workshop
and anything in between and this one
really went well great crowd great
questions if you want to see the video
for it you can look at the links below
and you'll find it we continued our
worlds of speculative fiction series at
the brookfield public library by talking
about michael moorcock and the cornelius
quartet in particular and his idea of
the multiverse and the eternal champion
another great conversation and that was
a lot of fun and then I also had my half
hour hagel online Q&A some some old
friends popped in for that so we had a
really great time talking about all
things Hagel related and even some
Heidegger some sort some some
Schopenhauer and some other people as
well so what else went on during the
month of September a lot of planning a
lot of marketing a lot of
behind-the-scenes stuff the fruit of
which we'll see come out a bit later I
also engaged in quite a bit of coaching
and philosophical counseling with
clients a bit of consulting work here
locally some tutoring online I'd have
even developed some resources some
additional resources for students that
I'll release later on and I we've been
in negotiating a commissioned video
project that somebody wanted us to do
for a while that is now online for me to
be working on this month and hopefully
producing the video by the end of the
month so that is the very first
commissioned video if you're interested
in that sort of thing you can always
email me
and Greg at reason I oh and i'll be
happy to consider any requests what else
been developing a lot of course
materials i actually had a budget time
during the day and during the week to do
that I've got a few more curious courses
courses on that platform and you can see
the link to that down below along with a
special offer we've been developing our
teachable reason I owe Academy it's not
yet live so you can't actually see it
yet but you're going to see some really
cool stuff once it does come out I
promise and I've been getting some stuff
ready to start working on udemy classes
there's a lot of stuff that we want to
start bringing out so learners can work
at their own pace worldwide using the
materials that that I've developed over
the you know the last 5-10 years i also
have been providing some video and some
other hand out content to pocket stoic
as they get their iOS app ready to
release that's going to be part of the
pocket stoic academy so that's cool been
trying to do some writing didn't get
much academic writing done have been
working a lot on talk prep getting
getting stuff ready for all of that and
i did do some writing in stoicism today
as the editor you know as we work up
towards stoic week and some writing in
iraq cysteine oh IDK my main blog that I
started about seven eight years ago
video work I got my six half hour hagel
videos for the month done we are now
finished with the section the very first
section of reason observing reason and
we're now into the second section you
might not have seen them because the
release of the public release of the
videos is a little bit behind i let my
Patrian subscribers and backers get to
see them a week to two weeks before the
general public is one of the perks from
my patreon supporters they should get
something back for helping out and
supporting a great project by the way if
you're interested in support
that project look at the link below
check it out a lot of cool perks that I
provide people so that is yeah that
that's the half hour Hagel thing I also
been releasing Aristotle videos I went
through and retitled a lot of videos it
turns out that youtube would rather have
you no more stuff at the front and not
not you know the name of the lecture
series so you know that's a lot of work
going through and redoing that and we
released the event videos I didn't get
to shooting the videos on philosophical
counseling or tutoring like I'd hoped
but that is on the docket for this month
so that is the month of September what
have we got coming up in the month of
October so this is probably the busiest
month of the year for me personally and
and for me Andy Andy as members of
reason I oh so let me talk about events
first because there's a number of
different events if you're here in the
Milwaukee area on october 10th 3 30 p.m.
at the Raynor library on marquette
campus i am going to be presenting as
part of the midwest seminar in ancient
and medieval philosophy have invited to
speak and my topic is going to be prior
ases in epictetus 'as stoic moral theory
it's going to be a close reading of some
of Epictetus as doctrines some some
pretty you know technical and intensive
discussion but if you're interested in
participating you can certainly come to
the event and you know you you know how
i speak i can reach a general audience
even when i'm discussing the most
technical of things on the 13th i am
continuing with the science fiction and
fantasy series at the brookfield public
library this month it is on one of my
favorite authors of all time philip k
dick and i'm going to be talking about
philip k dicks alternate America's that
we find in his stories including the man
in the high castle
Valis radio free album move through a
scanner darkly some of the really
excellent stories that he's written flow
my tears the policeman said we go on and
on and on about that you can tell I'm
really excited about that talk already
on the fifteenth I will be out in New
York at the stoic on conference leading
a workshop during the breakout sessions
entitled struggling with anger useful
stoic perspectives and practices where I
will be leading the participants through
some of the insights and practices and
strategies that primarily Seneca and
epictetus a little bit of Marcus
Aurelius a little bit of some other
thinkers as well but primarily those
those two big heavy hitters I'm going to
be helping people to think about how
they deal with their own anger and other
people's anger and living in a culture
of anger particularly during an election
year then once i'm back in milwaukee on
the 18th at the central location
Milwaukee Public Library we have booked
a room and we're going to be offering
that same workshop for free for anybody
who wants to attend so again for free
you don't have to pay like you would at
stoic on so its way for us to give back
during stoic week to to our community
we're so happy to be back here in
Milwaukee and so this is going to be a
really great lecture and workshop and
indeed so bring your anger questions
bring your anger problems and we will
try to work through them as much as we
can that's so that's the 18th 630pm and
then jumping ahead the half-hour Hagel
session online for this month we do a
google hangout for that look for the
link to be shared on my social media
it'll be on the twenty-sixth of October
which is a wednesday 5 to 6 p.m. central
time and you can come in you don't have
to know anything about Hagel just ask
whatever questions you want we always
give those price
already and then finally we haven't
completely got this fixed yet but
there's there's a strong likelihood that
i will be down in rockford university on
halloween the 31st of october giving a
talk on stoicism leadership and
entrepreneurship for the center for
ethics and entrepreneurship cited there
at rockford university so a lot of stoic
stuff this month as far as toxic oh i
should mention too if you're interested
in having me come in and give a talk at
your organization your university or
your college your your club whatever it
happens to be email me at greg at reason
I oh I'm always happy to consider things
and we can talk out what's available and
what might be of interest to you alright
so that is that portion of the work
we're also continuing doing all this
back behind the scenes marketing and
planning and I'm still doing a lot of
tutoring and coaching if you're
interested in those go to the reason I a
website if you want to know anything
more about philosophical counseling and
whether it's for you if you want to know
about tutoring especially since midterms
are going on for many people right about
now go to go to our website and you'll
see everything you need to know but like
I mentioned before we are now working
with the teachable learning platform
beautiful site and we're creating a an
academy specifically for reason I oh
we're going to have a lot of courses in
their first two courses are going to be
released this month one of them is for
free entirely free and it'll be released
during stoic week during stoic week I
have 21 roughly 20 to 40 minute videos
providing line by line in depth going
deep commentary on epictetus enchiridion
and i'll be releasing those not in my
main youtube channel but in my new
history of philosophy history of ideas
youtube channel
you'll see them being released on my
social media if you're interested in
that but it gets better so I'm going to
be taking all of those videos and I'm
going to be bundling them into an online
course that learners can work through at
their own pace so it's not just going to
have videos although that's by itself
pretty amazing stuff I mean what I've
done is what I my technique for the half
hour Hagel where I read the text and
then I comment on it for about half an
hour so I'm doing that with other texts
and i started with epictetus is
enchiridion you you know anyone who's
followed me knows how central that work
is for me and how many years I've been
studying it so i'll also be providing
handouts study questions quizzes all
these sorts of things and again totally
free so a way for me to give back during
stoic week and to increase awareness
then later towards the end of the month
we're going to be we're going to be
opening up the world views and values
class this is a class that I developed
and taught for a college online for
several years it was an incredibly
popular course you may have seen some of
the videos that I shot for it i think
there's about 45 anywhere from 20 minute
to 40 minute videos on plato Epictetus
booth this decart hobbs russo
Wollstonecraft's Martin Luther King I
think I'm leaving somebody out but I
can't quite remember offhand but those
are the key thinkers and it's it's
centered on theories of you know who the
human person is how they fit into
society how they fit into the larger
cosmos or universe really great course
really great introduction to nine key
thinkers in in philosophy and the world
of ideas I'm going to make it available
for a pretty inexpensive price fifty
dollars so that includes acts
to the videos the lesson pages the
handouts study questions quizzes all
sorts of cool stuff discussion forums
and you do it at your own pace so look
for that to be coming out later this
month will do announcements about it
I'll probably shoot a video on it as
well for people that are interested but
then we're going to be releasing a lot
of other courses on teachable as well
but that's not all we're all my courses
are going to be we're also working with
you to me and i'm already in curious and
i'm uploading more content to their
pocket stoic is hopefully releasing this
month and I've got some of my material
there and their Academy which you can
access which would be quite cool as well
what else have we got going on I should
mention that we're not doing as we had
scheduled we're not doing the online
courses that would meet weekly in part
because we want to sort of you know
rethink and retool and and relaunch that
aspect of reason I oh in January with
two courses so the Aristotle Nick and
McKay and ethics course and the
nietzsche birth of tragedy course are
now going to be in January and then
we'll be releasing those that's for
people who actually want to study with
me and want to have you know meetings
and and you know perhaps do homework and
back and forth and they want more you
know intensive experience studying with
me on that sort of thing so we're
putting that off we're also putting off
the intensive seminars until January as
well and then we're going to relaunch
those doing a lot of planning like I
said I'm doing quite a bit of writing
this month you look for some stuff
coming out in stoicism today and our
exes do know NTK going to do some other
writing in half hour Hagel beyond just
merely announcing here's the release of
the videos and I'm looking at a few
other platforms where I may be doing
some writing as well I don't want to say
which ones they are quite yet because
I like to get the writing done before i
start publicizing it video work look for
six half hour hagel videos to come out
later this month actually planning on
getting some work done on them later
this week so so there's there's you can
see that'll be coming up if you're in
patron you'll see the videos as they
come out if you're not a patreon
supporter you'll see them about two
weeks after they come out Aristotle core
concept videos we still have a lot of
those we're now up to book seven of the
Nicomachean ethics so watch for quite a
few of those being released I will be
shooting some personal videos and I will
be shooting some videos about tutoring
and philosophical counseling services
later on this month and like I mentioned
during stoic week we're going to have
all those enchiridion videos coming out
so that's that's also quite cool that
pretty much wraps it up for the month of
October it's a lot of work but it's a
great work to have again if you're
interested in tutoring or philosophical
counseling and coaching services if
you'd like to talk with me about booking
me to come in and give a presentation or
facilitate a workshop or a discussion
for your organization or institution
email me at Greg at reason I oh and I'll
be really happy to talk with you about
it our calendar is starting to fill up
already for first and second quarter of
two thousand sixteen so you want to get
it get a good lead on on those sorts of
things otherwise have a great month of
October and don't forget to sign up for
the free online stoic in a stoic week
class that Donald Robertson put together
also keep an eye out for my epictetus
class and have a great a month and study
some stoic philosophy